ladies and gentlemen live from a
stunning estate it is the Tim Dillon
show thank you for joining us we are
here from Beverly Hills California in
the middle of a nationwide quarantine in
response to the pandemic of kovat 19
which we all know is fake but we are
doing our part
pretending along with everyone else that
there is a disease out there called
corona virus and that people are dying
from it we know full well we know full
well that everybody who's dying never
existed and that all of the nurses and
the doctors are actors hired by who by
dr. Anthony thought she by Bill Gates
and Greta Van Susteren I don't know I'm
just saying that maybe she's involved
and I learned this all watching planned
emic planned emic the YouTube
documentary from a thick woman a thick
older lass who looks like she flogs her
children after she's had a few cocktails
of course the YouTube thugs whom I
respect thanks for having us capitulated
to social pressure and yanked the
documentary off and I have no I've never
agreed with that method of dealing with
misinformation making it sexier by
removing it people want to hear what I
just said I started the show and I said
coronavirus is fake people want to hear
that people want to hear that there's an
Orwellian plan that's in place I think
that is actually comforting instead of
the idea that this is a chaotic
period of time it's a mess nobody knows
what's going on there is no plan
good or bad yes people are gonna use
this crisis to accelerate things they
wanted to do you will leave this crisis
with less freedom
you left 911 with less freedom every day
you wake up by the time you go to bed
guess what you have less freedom it's
true you're not paying attention to it
because you're you're out you're doing
things there's some credibility issues
with the woman who did plan demmick by
the way I don't care what you believe I
don't know what I believe is this being
overstated exaggerated probably do we
know that I don't know that how
contagious is it how transmissible is it
I don't know any of that I speak to
doctors I speak to some nurses I don't
know please stop messaging me plan
Demick okay enjoy your life find a way
to enjoy your life I'm deadly serious
about this there's not much of it left
figure out a way to enjoy your life and
it is not watching planned emic is fowey
shady probably he's been a government
official for decades they're all shady
they all make deals I don't know what
Bill and Melinda are doing I don't know
I'm sure there's a good with the bad I
don't know if Bill Gates is Satan I
don't think he is but I'm also not
willing to hand a handful of
billionaires control over the planet
they've taken it anyway whether I'm
willing to hand it to them or not
they've they've got it you can wrestle
it back potentially but I'm taking this
seriously
I've made a pact with myself I will not
visit my family under any circumstances
I will not attend a family function
I don't care States open up I don't care
if they find a vaccine I don't care if
coronavirus disappears off the face of
the earth and it's ten years from now I
still will not do it won't do it I will
not go and spend time with my family
because I owe that to the heroes I owe
to them
I owe to the heroes to be steadfast in
my commitment I am deleting them out of
my phone they're done they're done now
people are on zoom' calls with their
family no thank you
it's too tempting to be on a zoom call
with your family because you might think
hey down the road I'm gonna visit those
people and break bread with them not me
no I'm steadfast so I'll tell you that
that's very important and I want you to
know how seriously I'm taking it for the
heroes even in ten years when no one's
even mentioned coronavirus I'm still and
many of my family members running to
death bed I still will honor the work
the heroes have done and not visit my
family I've deleted them from my phone
I've gotten rid of them because it is
not safe I will not be sending birthday
presents or wedding presents asked Ben I
will not send an Amazon package of
coronavirus to his home no no I won't do
it it kills me to not do it it destroys
me as a human being to not do it all I
want to do is give him a present for his
wedding he chose not to have I
to buy him a big whatever go on the
registry I don't know what the [ __ ] they
want over there a juicer I don't know I
didn't look but I would give it to them
and I'd wrap it in a shiny bow I would
night I drop it right at their door and
now I can't cuz it'll be full of Corona
balls and I won't do it I love giving
gifts
I love providing for the people that I
care about giving them a thing watching
them open it with with big bright eyes
nothing would make me happier than to
give this man a wedding present but I
can't do it because why because I don't
go in front of a nurse and spit in her
face and it would be doing that I'm not
getting any eye even before the pandemic
I don't want to be out in the open and
telling people that I kind of knew what
was gonna go on but even before in his
pandemic I was not sending presents to
my family through the mail because I
know a little bit about virology I know
a little bit about the way things work I
wasn't just willy-nilly sending things
through the mail that you're opening up
and that it could kill you sorry I've
been taking than bicep this is the new
world we're living in and I'm doing it
because I want to honor the work that is
being done on my behalf
another thing I'm not doing I am no
longer entertaining the idea of having a
friend that is not worth 10 million
dollars I'm done with that
why because I want to only be friends
with philanthropists that give their
money to better society I want to spend
time with people that giveth of
themselves
they giveth what they haven't that's who
I'm spending time with so it's very hard
to be a philanthropist
if you don't have an eight-figure bank
account so that's who I'm choosing to
spend my time with because of the corona
pandemic that's why I'm ordering food
every day and not cooking because of the
economy
I've chosen to not cook or clean or wash
dishes because of the corona pandemic
yes I could fry an egg while people
starve in the street I choose not to I
choose to order things even when they're
completely unnecessary like napkins and
bottles of water but I order them
because I want people to live sorry
sorry I like a plague with the only
thing I can do is lay on my couch and
order post mates that's what I can do
other people can do other things they
have different skill sets some of them
can intubate patients some of them can
deliver things to the local hospital I
can stay home order food not send people
presents and not spend any time with
family I choose to do that why because I
want to win I want to win can you fight
like I'm fighting can you fight are you
gonna roll over start cooking start
reaching out to family members and
asking them how they are and making
plans to eventually see them like a
terrorist have a little [ __ ] class
how about that stop sending me Plan
Demick
this was planned or not I've adjusted
and I suggest you do too because you're
a hero whether you know it or not I
don't know what Anthony foul she's doing
I don't I've never gotten a flu vaccine
and I've never had the flu what does
that mean I don't know I don't know
that's not a scholarly paper that's not
peer-reviewed science
I just never walked into his CVS and
said get the needle out I've never
walked into a what now Raymond cup has
gotten a lot of flu shots I don't know
he I don't I guess he's and I think he's
got in the floor I don't know some
vaccines are good some vaccines are bad
that's what it is
I don't know which ones are which all of
you do all of my friends know everything
immediately overnight about vouching and
the World Health Organization there is
no health there is no such thing as
health how about that I'm gonna go even
further you want to conspiracy I'll give
you the big one I'll give you the big
the bigger one the biggest one there is
no such thing as how you're not healthy
there's no such thing it doesn't exist
let me prove it to you friend of mine
was healthy got in a car accident and
died how healthy were they couldn't
handle a little pile up on the Long
Island Expressway died instantly not
healthy to me Adele was fat now she's
thin
look good fat doesn't look good thin
sounds great in both incarnations didn't
care about her fat I don't care about
her thin she's it's good the songs are
good she sings she's she deserves her
fame and a hundred and fifty million
dollars what she looks like doesn't
affect you be fat be thin doesn't matter
doesn't really matter it's better to be
thin than fat harder for a lot of people
but better but doesn't necessarily make
you healthy I know a lot of thin people
that are [ __ ] don't kid yourself thin
[ __ ] walking around waiting to
drop dead what is this health what is it
I don't understand what it is you go to
a doctor's office and they tell you
their Lord's God who are they I
subscribe to I've never trusted Western
medicine when you start to get to a
certain level of wealth and you live in
California you get very skeptical of
Western medicine I'm starting to connect
with the tribes and many of the peoples
that I feel are like many white women of
a certain means age group and
denomination of money I now I'm starting
to think about chakras and energy and
auras it's not all [ __ ] okay it's
not all [ __ ] you get you know people
are depressed and anxious in this
country and here's here's what people
aren't gonna want to hear here's what
people don't want to understand there is
and I'm gonna tell you this is gonna
sound controversial people aren't gonna
like this there's no such thing as
cancer
you just have a bad attitude do you
understand do you get it you have a bad
attitude you're you're you're cranky and
you're negative and that little ball of
negativity becomes a cancer you eat
sugar and white bread all day you get
you crash you think it's depression and
anxiety it's a bad diet and then the
pharmaceutical companies come in and
then they try to save you with their
medications it's a cycle the over the
kept my mother all her whole life took
over-the-counter medication sudafed
everything she could get our hands on
pep herself up put a little pep in her
step clear out her nasal cavity make her
feel better she had hay fever and
allergies and every every ailment you
could imagine every plant that was on
the planet was conspiring to kill my
mother
personally they all had meetings and
they wanted to just do her in every tree
was a potential threat every vine that
hung down was a potential deadly
situation for my mother unless she could
put a few sudafed down her throat it's
not good stop with the dayquil stop
taking bright orange tablets of goo stop
drinking robitussin unless you're a
white young rapper you don't need the
over-the-counter [ __ ] my grandmother
used to get sick you know what she did
she had chicken soup and water and she
got over it they all lived to their late
80s we have aisles and aisles of [ __ ]
[ __ ] in the grocery store and the
pharmacist you do not need you do not
need this [ __ ] mucin acts it just
alleviates your symptoms it doesn't cure
or heal you understand your chakra
understand your spirit guides you know
God a spirit guide it's because you're
clogging your mouth up with Robo tots
and cut it out of there get a spirit
guide
my spirit guide is a racist so I had to
get another one
my spirit guide was a very racist being
I didn't realize that when I first got
them but after a while they started
displaying signs were very troubling in
the beginning it was all they appeared
in light and they would you know walk me
through the gardens of life then they
started talking about the protocols of
the Elders of Zion
I was concerned I'm now looking for
another guide spiritually to take me
through the universe have you ever felt
healthy in a Walgreens have you ever
walked into a CVS and thought that was a
place to vote it to health truly if you
ever walked into a CVS that said thank
God I'm in a place where I can get
medicine or a tub of cookie dough
because that's what drugstores are in
America you can get vicodin and you can
get Red Baron pizza which is not bad
frozen pizza as they go but that's what
drugstores are in this country the
potions the soaps your skin is bad
because you eat dairy my skin is bad
because I eat dairy I eat the milk of
another animal it is not healthy but I
do it my skin gets red I get rosacea I
get eczema and why does that happen
because of my diet because what I
consume and then I go and I get CeraVe
and all these garbage [ __ ]
moisturizers and courtesans and your
face gets addicted to what you're
putting on it and it's bad and it just
cover because you're unwilling to
realize that the problems are of your
own making many of them there is no such
thing as aids do you understand me you
have AIDS it's it's it's God's Way of
saying enough already
enough
don't always swallow spit a little out
save a little for later don't have it be
a foregone conclusion that you just take
it all down into your abdomen for Christ
God's looking at you every time you suck
a dick and one that by the time you get
to the end of it he goes for Christ's
spit a little of it out take half of it
stop taking it all down every time is
not Thanksgiving you're getting aids
aids is not real Tony found she created
aids with God
Bill Gates Tony foul Qi and God created
aids they have a corporation they
patented the vaccine for AIDS some of
what I'm saying here is incredibly
important some of it is less so you have
to find out what is what we're in the
quarantine we're in a stunning a state I
don't have to tell you any of this you
should be figuring it out yourself many
of you will never understand what's
truly great you will not see any value
your slugs many of you it's not my fault
you crawl on the ground
you haven't evolved into into being that
can handle the information that I'm
telling you multiple sclerosis isn't
real
they're just clumsy they're just clumsy
people Parkinson's disease is people
that want attention yeah we see we see
your Uncle Frank we get it how about you
stop the shaking and come up with a
funny anecdote
I've never met a pharmacist who I didn't
want to kill they're rude thoughtless
people they think they're doctors you're
not you sling pills in a [ __ ] Walmart
you're nothing
Western medicine is a problem I try to
align my chakras who's your spirit guide
mine yes [ __ ] trying to think he's
[ __ ] I'm not in touch with my
spiritual you got a line a line
everyone's like I need health insurance
you need a [ __ ] clue
you need a clue it's over stop trying to
figure it out out there planned um it's
it's all bad the whole thing's bad
feeding your kids a bowl of garbage
every day is bad and then wondering why
they turn around and they bring a gun to
homeroom maybe part of it is that you're
feeding them a bowl of [ __ ] like my
parents fed me a bowl of sugar fast food
frozen food ice cream cakes cookies pies
tarts big steaks they don't care
just eat something and get away from us
I should have been a Navy SEAL how I was
fed a good diet I would have been a Navy
SEAL but my parents failed don't fail
your children everybody you know that I
love magic spoon cereal it is a Kido
cereal it is a low carb low sugar like
no sugar cereal that simulates the
experience you had when you ate cereal
as a kid they have a lots of different
flavors they have a fruity cereal that
it's like Fruity Pebbles now it's like
Froot Loops there's a blueberry cereal
when there's chocolate and then there's
more of a vanilla flavor magic spoon is
great and if you go to magic spoon comm
slash Tim Dylan you were going to love
the cereal I mean you're gonna like it I
eat it I'm gonna try to message them and
get like an Apple Jacks flavor I like a
fall flavor but right now it's this
summer so the fruity pebble flavor and
the blueberry flavor these are killer
they're part of a healthy diet okay so
you can start your day with these and if
you like something sweet you can even
eat them at night as a treat after you
have a keto or Paleo day and you've
eaten healthy and you need something
that feels good and again people say oh
it's a little pricey it's pricey because
the flavor you know you know I think
it's more they used to use monk fruit
like the way that they sweeten the
cereal is with expensive extracts from
fruit and things like that it's not
sugar it's not added and processed it's
not garbage and right now we're all
thinking about our health you know
everybody that I know is thinking about
their health we have to we're in the
middle of this [ __ ] crazy
unprecedented time where health is now
more important than anything else so
it's it's time to get healthy but you
don't want to give up all the stuff that
you like some people love cereal it's a
great way to start the day it's easy
it's a treat doesn't take a lot to make
some people just can't you know do the
eggs every morning they don't have the
time kids running around they want to
and even listen this is great to get
your kids if your kids love this type of
cereal feeding this cereal to your kids
instead of giving them sugar is amazing
but I know it's a little bit on the
pricier side but again what's the value
in health what's the value in being
healthy right now health is invaluable
which means it you cannot put a price on
it you know what I mean isn't there a
song you can't put a price on love I
think so stop doesn't matter let's just
move on the cereal is good
it's tasty and it's nice it's something
nice to have something nice to start
your day with some cereal that it's
healthy and good so here's what I want
you to do right now right now pull the
car over go to magic spoon comm slash
Tim Dylan TI m di ll oh and grab a
variety back and try it today if you use
promo code Tim Dylan I'd check out you
get free shipping so there's no cost to
ship this cereal to your house this is
part of your diet this is one of the
meals of your day done and it tastes
good done don't think about it
you're on keto you're on paleo this is
breakfast it's done you did it you got
it it's good boom got to worry about
lunch and dinner
that's all I've taken your breakfast and
now what you usually use for breakfast
cuz keto and paleo these things are hard
because choices are limited right we
know this so now that eggs bacon or that
turkey egg to that omelet you're gonna
make with a bunch of vegetables that's
very you know you know protein dense and
really really good and nutritious now
eat it for lunch or dinner cause
breakfast is very easy to do paleo and
keto it's very easy but now I've taken
that breakfast and I've moved it to
lunch or dinner now you only have to
figure out one meal it's much easier add
a bowl of magic spoon to your routine
it's much better I'm telling you right
now telling you right now I have been
using it and I've gained 30 pounds
that's a joke
I'm a comedian and that's not true you
understand comedy isn't true it's funny
magic spoon comm slash Tim Dylan try the
cereal take a photo of yourself eating
the cereal send it to me and if you are
attractive I will repost it thank you
I'm just telling you it is what it is if
you don't want the vaccine don't take it
don't get it if you do want it get it it
ain't coming we're probably not even
gonna get one everyone's worried about
the corona virus vaccine it's probably
not gonna happen
they're gonna go about it another way
there it's not gonna vaccinate you
they're gonna just figure out a way to
not let you leave your house I don't
know what to tell you so if you're never
allowed to leave your house again what's
the solution
here it is get a stunning estate get a
stunning estate if it is not stunning
you're in trouble two people will help
them by the way you know my aunt reached
out to me and she's like you know she's
loves disaster porn so everyday she's
telling me about new ways Kovac can kill
you you know he it's in the mail it's in
your deck forever and I said listen you
got to go with God and then eventually
she transitioned right quickly and she's
like there's so many people dying and I
just hope Realtors can sell houses I'm
trying to sell my house always remember
we're a boomer comes from a boomer is is
it an animal I've studied for a long
time in every statement of concern you
must study the boomer understand the way
the boomer thinks watch the way the
boomer moves towards the wine away from
the responsibility is responsibility
over there away from that towards the
wine towards the cigar Oh a Golf Club
the boomer the boomer in every statement
of concern there is cloaked
self-interest it is the boomers
inherited the earth and lit it on fire
and are now going it's a little bit hot
it's a little bit hot and I don't like
it so when the boomer begins a soliloquy
about disease and horror and famine or
climate change very soon after you will
see how they're personally affected by
it and now they don't really give a [ __ ]
about and it'll be very quick you just
gotta you just gotta pay attention
to the Boomer to which I said I just say
go with God now respond to every tax go
with God go with God
figure it out sorry it's not my problem
the woman from Planned emic does not
hold the keys to the jail cell that
we're all in she doesn't what was that
we just heard something sound like a
squirrel jumping to the tree was it a
squirrel I think so a lot of people
unemployed in this goddamn country every
squirrel is a potential issue every
squirrel is a potential [ __ ] front
page of the LA Times we're just laying
here in our own blood just another two
young promising men covered in blood in
a stunning estate and they'll come in to
sell it they'll sell it while we lay
here while we breathe and grasp for air
well our carotid arteries are still you
know spitting blood they'll come right
in here and walk around our dead bodies
and take a look at the view and they
should it's a circle of life Adele is
still fat
in my opinion she needs to get thinner
what if Adele what if it was like that
movie theater where a dog got thinner
and thinner every year until it was
uncomfortable what if Adele in six
months is just bones wouldn't that be
hilarious
it's fun to see fat people get very very
thin and then thin people get very very
fat and people should do that people
should do that more and I mean where
it's scary on both ends like how great
would it be if Adele got bony and and
scarily thin like where everyone was
nervous remember how thin Calista
Flockhart was with Ally McBeal where her
waist was the size of a compact disc
and everybody was like is she gonna can
this work have you ever seen someone so
thin were you like can this even work
you just see the blood shooting all
through their body their skin is
translucent it's like when you stuff a
sandwich into a small ziploc bag and it
doesn't fit that's the way their body
presents their skin is thin just hanging
on their bones they're all skin and
bones I wish that for Adele I would like
to see Adele thin thin thin where
everybody got uncomfortable and then I
would like to see a very thin person and
I don't know who let's pick out a very
thin person someone who's very thin like
like they have a problem like yes but
maybe not public problem but when you
look at them you go god I want them to
get very fat Laura Dern's pretty thin
Laura Dern's not that thin but I know
she is thin but I don't think she has a
problem but I'd like to see Dern fat I'd
like to see Laura Dern good example I'd
like to see Laura turn get so fat that
people were terrified of running into
her because they wouldn't know what to
do I like when people get so thin or
thoughts so fat that's just the thought
of bumping into them Mikula makes you
have a panic attack cuz you don't know
what to do like if Adele got so thin
that you didn't know what to do anymore
you wanted to ask her if she had a rare
blood cancer which doesn't exist I mean
that's people gonna be so mad at this
episode because people are so stupid
yeah and people don't understand comedy
yeah so what they will do is they're
gonna they're gonna either send me
information that cancer exists right
okay or they will then talk about why I
need to just watch plan Demick again I
don't care about plan Domecq it's a
clever
name what does it matter it would truly
if you want to go out go out go out
don't wear a mask do it do whatever you
want
let them arrest you let them be the bad
guy you live your life to the extent
that you can live it don't want the
vaccine don't get the vaccine don't get
the chip buy a gun
stay [ __ ] alert pay attention to all
those things you should do but just
cocooning yourself in your [ __ ] on
your couch watching these [ __ ] hack
doctors on YouTube isn't and isn't an
answer people are sick people are dying
is it a lot is it to man is the
mortality rate lower than it who knows
no one knows is a government line yes
yes cuz they always have been stop
sending me these [ __ ] doctors to like
well the mortality rate is lower than
good go out go bowling go get sloppy go
do something you want to do all these
states are opening back up we're quit
you know we're heading back into it now
I get it
this quarantine is sucked it's been
frustrating but you're gonna come on the
other end of it with a renewed
appreciation for masturbating and not
talking to others get rid of your friend
group get rid of them you're gonna when
this quarantine opens you're gonna go
out with a bunch of your friends ago I
want to be home whacking off yeah truly
yeah that's what's gonna happen cuz
you've realized that you don't need
people you really don't get the cereal
get digital get quick get quickly
acquainted with the digital sphere yes
it sucks but it's not going away put a
chip in yourself
how about that when they go to chip you
already have I already [ __ ] have it I
got a better chip than you can chip me
with stop pretending like you're not
gonna like the chip a little you're
gonna show your friends the chip some
people gonna put a chip in their dick
they'll be like I chipped in my dick
you're gonna get two chip chips coming
yes it's gonna be it's yeah she won't
have any more freedom stop getting mad
at me I'm a clown starts ended playing
demux other people that can do something
about it what [ __ ] me to do planned
Emek do you think I gotta find one
hundred thirty six thousand people and
integrate these dogs and cats but more
than that send them plan Demick who do I
[ __ ] have out there I perform it
[ __ ] slob houses you want me to do
you're not wrong you're not right either
there is no wrong or right it's over
things making sense so when this
quarantine ends dress crazy we're a shoe
on your head like that guy vermin
supreme all bets are off now
you choose your future put a chip in
yourself I'm you know I'm cautiously
optimistic about our potential when we
reopen I think that people will
potentially embrace the new economy
which of course will be everything that
happened will now just happen with 75%
of it not happening and I think that'll
be great I think people will enjoy being
75 people in a comedy club that seats
500 and strewn around the room and they
can barely hear each other and I think
comedy will work I really do I think
comedy will work with a small handful of
people spread out in a large
room and I think that that should happen
as soon as possible I think that's
actually the best way to see comedy I
think comedy will happen I think should
be outside with masks and gloves
temperature Jack's yes I think that's
the best way to watch a comedian with a
mask on I think the best way to enjoy a
restaurant experience is to have a
waitress dressed in a hazmat suit hand
you a brownie sundae it all makes sense
don't tell me it doesn't it's about time
to go back to the woods folks get the
guns go to the woods
keep the Wi-Fi until we can go back the
way we were it's pointless
it's pointless to do these half-measures
we either open or we don't we need to
slowly open I understand that but the
experiences have to be something like
you kind of remember you know and
they're not gonna be so I'm not doing
clubs that are 25% full I'm waiting for
those gloves to be full I'm waiting for
people to feel comfortable going out for
people to come in and enjoy themselves I
will not be performing to only 75
psychopaths that are the first people in
a comedy club I will say this again if
the first thing you do is attend a
comedy show you should have a chip put
in your head you should have ten chips
put in your [ __ ] head
if the first thing you do when
quarantine lifts is to go eat frozen
chicken fingers at a comedy club you
should be put in jail you [ __ ] loser
stay the [ __ ] out of the mall Jesus
Christ when they open the gate go
somewhere else go to a [ __ ] comedy
club you're eating queso
get a [ __ ] purpose to be on this
planet please enough people keep asking
me what a comedy clubs gonna open here's
here's the answer who cares
truly who cares that's the answer
there's 20 million people that don't
have [ __ ] jobs right now there's a
hundred million people not in labor
force and you want to know when the
chuckle hut will be open we do when do
you think we'll be able to see I don't
know I want to perform again but I'm
doing it here in a stunning a state I
will perform anywhere the people are
online I'm entertaining the people
online if the people are in a club I'll
entertain them there I'm gonna do shows
when I come back I will do it shows
exclusively for the heroes I will do all
shows for the heroes only you will now
be allowed on my show of you're not a
hero period I'll be doing shows for the
people who work at door - grocery store
employees first responders nurses
doctors the heroes only the ones that
have died only the dead heroes I'll be
performing for the the heroes that have
are deceased and I'll be paid I'll be
paid dearly
we will there will be no breaks on the
ticket prices when we're back by the way
you'll pay and you'll pay dearly for
this entertainment okay I think we
should charge you more there will be no
if you come to my show you will not be
donating no proceeds of your ticket will
be going to anyone but me they will not
be going to a food bank
they might be going to they'll be going
to my bank don't you worry about it
don't worry if you come to see Tim Dylan
you're not gonna walk out unknowingly
supporting nurses you're gonna pay me
and I'm gonna spend the money how I see
fit
okay don't worry about that I know
there's a lot of people that are
concerned right now if they come and
they buy a ticket to the Tim Dylan show
what's that gonna do he's not gonna put
food in the food bank the hell it will
the hell it will
well here's the thing with food banks
why can't we just have post mates
deliver people food for free why do we
need a food bank with a long line it's
demoralizing don't we have the
technology you know to just deliver
people the food I'm asking you why is
this happening like a you're talking
like a food drive right where people go
door-to-door and just drop off bags of
crack yeah why aren't we doing that I
don't know I don't want to see the lines
it's depressing yeah you know when you
see the long food line yeah it depresses
me you know why don't we have people
that can go to those families and kill
them humanely euthanize them why are we
not offering in this country euthanasia
right and I mean this very seriously why
are we not offering to euthanize the
portion of the workforce
we're America we find a way to do it and
win we are America why are we not having
people show up to your home with a
needle and putting you to bed once and
for all could buy Sleeping Beauty why do
we make people suffer through the
indignities of going through
unemployment euthanize them is this not
more humane do you know how hard
unemployment is I do because I look at
Facebook
and everyone on Facebook in New York
they're comedians and they're getting
unemployment I don't know what the [ __ ]
from because they didn't make any money
anyway but they're getting unemployment
they're like I spent 82 hours on hold
and then finally everybody who gets
unemployment to get it is some accident
to some accident happening like see like
I fell asleep I hit my head I had a
concussion and I woke up in the middle
of the night and finally I was on the
phone with the person and it just went
through but why not why not use science
instead of figuring out a vaccine we
know how to kill people we don't need a
vaccine if we think smart we got to
lower the unemployment rate and we're
not gonna do it through people working
shall we go
so we got to figure out how best to
euthanize people and children and
children we got the whole family units
gotta go because what a little Timmy and
Tommy and then Barbara and Mohamed and
laquanda I want to make sure I'm
representing all races what are all
those kids gonna do nothing nothing good
you know week why not and listen why not
return to I mean listen and they I'm not
saying this is a joke what is inherently
wrong with child labor some form of
children working because if not we're
going to have to euthanize them because
otherwise they're just sitting around
you know I have ideas leukemia is not
real it's kids that want attention and
many of them are pale get rid of them
I've had enough of them haven't you if
your kid and you don't have 10 million
followers on tik-tok we're coming for
you and you're going back to wherever
you came from
we can't support large amounts of people
that don't pull their weight which is
children in my head I feel like there's
guys outside that wanted to do a home
invasion but are so entertained and and
fascinated by what's happening right now
they're just sitting there with loaded
guns waiting for me to finish so they
could come in here and shoot us in the
end but instead they're listening right
now to the Gospel as many of you are
because these are questions these are
real questions I want to know when the
important things about our society when
does karaoke come back when can
disgusting middle-aged divorcees go
drown their sorrows and booze and sing
journey in a roadside bar when can
karaoke come back everybody has that
friend now that's asking when
something's coming back and it doesn't
need to happen at all you know do like
when's midnight bowling coming back you
know where they light up the lanes it's
like what is your life what is wrong
when's midnight bowling when's when's
karaoke gonna come back when can you go
to that diner in New York City where the
waitress is saying shut up ah I'm
rooting for the virus call foul Chico
gates they're right Kip I'm all I'm
trying to [ __ ] knock it on this T
population agenda stop asking about
midnight bowling when's laser-tag gonna
come back
there's always somebody running their
[ __ ] mouth about something that
doesn't need to come back all the good
things are things you can do for
yourself you know killing yourself using
drugs and alcohol stimulating your
genitals you can do all of that yourself
foster a dog how about that foster a cat
why does it want foster a cat it's kind
of hilarious be kind of fun to people
foster cats they do but you can kind of
just get a cat you know it'll be funny
to foster a cat the idea of the cat the
cat has no attachment to you at all
right wouldn't just leave probably Oscar
tries to escape every day yeah
no one cares cats don't care about human
beings they hate them that's what cats
the funniest animal they hate human
beings they're disgusted by human beings
the way they look at them they like why
why are you imprisoning me in your home
I ate you I genuinely hate you I like
cats watching Tiger King they're at
least like God it's just we're [ __ ]
all across the board huh doesn't matter
how big and powerful we are we're just
Nicolas Cage is gonna be in the new
Tiger king movie snooze dude the real
Tiger King is much better you know I
mean it's gonna come out years from now
nobody's gonna care it was a moment we
all had a tiger King moment I've been in
every episode
it's a quarantine we're gonna have
things from white chicks are gonna be
like when this is over like white chicks
are gonna be like how was your car how
is your car
James learn Mandarin I just baked
rosemary focaccia bread all day that we
just cashed on inheritance tax we got
our financial planner [ __ ] around with
our trusts give his little cash went out
to Palm Springs
that around stargazing we read through
this Airbnb because I hate my life and
it's fun to pretend that I'm living
another life and you can get good deals
on Airbnb ease now but I'll have to
leave this Airbnb soon and go back to
the nightmare that I've created for
myself a nightmare that at least proves
entertaining from any view thank God
I'll participate
I'm getting very close to doing a zoom
comedy show let me tell you why let me
tell you why I want to have a breakdown
on a zoom comedy show no one's having
breakdowns on the zoom [ __ ] why why are
you not having a breakdown on a digital
platform that it's I mean is there a
better way to have a breakdown I want to
get on one of these go what the [ __ ] is
this what are we doing what are we doing
are we that desperate for [ __ ] laughs
that we're on a zoom what's great about
a virtual private network of VPN right
now is you can go on the internet and
not be tracked by the man you can also
get British Netflix right so if you want
to get like different programming from
all over the world a VPN will allow you
to do it
okay disguises your location it inhibits
the totalitarian fascist government
structures from figuring out what you're
doing you can buy anything get out there
and you know have fun live it up VPN is
going to be extremely important because
all everything now is being tracked you
are being tracked there's going to be a
chip in your head but for right now a
VPN is the way to go a lot of the people
that want to come on the show we
communicate with them through
P n because they are people at Whitney
web that are doing very important work
that want to send you things don't want
to be tracked writing great articles you
know you know so this is the reality
don't you like a VPN I use it all the
time isn't it great
yeah I can watch shows from Japan if I
want like spirited away it's really easy
to use what what what are you watching
spirited away what is that it's in the
copy I don't know what it is are you
lying how are they gonna believe us if
you [ __ ] lie how are they gonna
believe us about the product when you
[ __ ] make up a show from Japan I
thought it was one of those anime things
you and your friends from [ __ ] Echo
Park like you [ __ ] lie to the
audience they trust you they trust you
and they trust your recommendations you
gonna say do you watch a show you don't
even watch apologize to them I'm very
sorry guys you've been just lies
apparently all the time we don't know
this you just makes up shows I can watch
spirited away from Japan don't [ __ ]
listen to him I love British Netflix I
would never [ __ ] lie to you
I love UK Netflix [ __ ] every show on
there's grain i watch it oh it's great
i watch [ __ ] is there bit is it big
boy that's good I like there that's cool
is there a bit of pie and it's about a
guy who comes in and he asks a woman if
there's a bit of pie and she has someone
they fall in love then there's um i
watch a show called drags it or beat it
and which way you either have to go
bragh [ __ ] or you have to check off
these are all on British Netflix yeah so
watch that
but it's good listen it's fun to steal
things
that's really what it comes down to it's
fun to break in and stuff and steal
stuff so if you have a VPN you can steal
cuz you're not allowed to access these
different entertainment services and you
can you can watch shows from all over
the world that's kind of fun you should
do it
you all go tracked by the government
what is the deal here what is the thing
just tell me what it is I don't want to
express VPN dot-com / Tim Dylan
expressvpn com / Tim Dylan if you need a
VPN and you enjoy my show this is the
way to support me and privacy if you
value privacy and freedom and like the
show this is the move right if you value
privacy and freedom Express VP Express
VPM expressvpn if you want to watch
things from japan expressvpn you can
have anything buy drugs if you want if
you can handle them don't develop a
problem later in life expressvpn enjoy
legal aged porn don't pee bad use the
VPN to watch British Netflix jingle it's
not it's truly not no it is not no it is
not if you listen back to it it's pretty
good
alright go do that folks how many how
long have we done here we're at 50/50
use the restroom but I'll stick it out
for another 10 minutes because I care
about my audience you watch planned emic
again I know somebody could tell me
watch will you go to watch with him
if somebody told me hey thought you
created AIDS I go yeah that's not good
I mean a like at a certain point folks
are certain when you know what I know
what do you what do you think who do you
think you're sending any of this to get
the archives kit on the patreon I've
been there done that yeah they're bad I
get it yeah they've done some naughty
things the rulers some of them are bad
some of them are worse some of them are
good you know all I do I mean Ben I saw
this video of a monkey grabbing this
girl and dragging her away Ben told me
what did you tell me pedophiles are
training monkeys to kidnap kids so they
write little motorcycles and then grab
kids and run away with them every day on
this planet is another horror I mean
every minute every waking moment of this
existence is another horror that cannot
be described how can we still put this
into words how do we not walking around
screaming all day and throwing ourselves
on the floor how can we still manage
words is that true
is there anything verifiable of it's
true but someone told me that like human
traffickers are using like monkeys now
to grab kids and go away with them I
mean I haven't done any real I've really
dive on it but that's what I've heard
imagine the guy at the meeting that
brings that idea up and then everybody
just looks at him like he's a [ __ ]
God everybody looks at him like he's
when Wolfgang Puck decided to put goat
cheese on pizza not mozzarella cheese
and everybody doubted him at first but
then they were like [ __ ] yeah you know
somebody's like we thought you were
crazy and then all of a sudden these
goddamn kids started showing up with
monkeys
and we were like God imagine a human
trafficker being like one of the things
turn around for you guys well when we
started using primates it was getting
pretty bad up until then we were getting
arrested
even our kingpins like Jeffrey Epstein
were getting killed in their prison
cells I mean it's the next Jeffrey
Epstein going to be a gorilla is that
what you're is that the logical
conclusion of this when we walk this out
it would be great to see animals start
participating in the sex trade do you
think the monkeys know what's going on
that's another question yes we're
talking about monkeys kidnapping
children for the purposes of human
trafficking this is a news show we're
doing the news this is literally the
news now I don't know what bird that is
in the back but I'm gonna go out and I'm
gonna [ __ ] it to death after this birds
never get raped every night this bird
birds are never raped every night this
bird right what is it every night I
think it's a mockingbird
what rapes a bird nothing so you should
do this on the podcast and then I would
try to like I would try to make these
things into bits on stage but now that
there is no stage I just literally am
left with the idea of I'm gonna Google
later do birds get raped yeah other
birds maybe or like a snake maybe a
snake raping a bird I mean probably not
like you mean like raping it like raping
it raping it like holding it against its
will and [ __ ] it isn't that would
rapists have you probably just other
birds right I don't think anything else
I've seen monkeys [ __ ] frogs like they
use them like flashlights they open a
frog's mouth and jack off with the Frog
you are now to be silent for the rest of
the episode
you've hit your quota you've talked
enough I've seen my monkeys use frogs
like flashlights this is the [ __ ]
corners of the internet he spends his
time in you should be watching planned
dammit what would be great as if we
ended this show if I just crawled into
the fire we're just in a quiet Street
here next week is our 200th episode of
the Tim Dylan show first starting of
course has Tim Dylan going to hell Tim
Dylan goes to hell
what was it today the villain is going
to hell yeah Tim Dylan is going to hell
was the original show we started with a
great rate hump a gas digital New York
City in the East Village under the
tutelage of Luis che Gomez and Ralph
Sutton and friends with them both to
this day and when do we start 2016
summer yeah so in the summer of 2016 I
think June 2016 and the show's grown
race till New York I'm here now we have
rayon frequently but the Tim Dylan show
was born when when did we start this
particular show I think August you're
right like episode 160 something like
that what episode 160 we started in
August to Tyndale show we're not even a
year into it yeah around the it's a 200
episodes of the podcast we are doing
something special we don't know what we
have some very special guests
potentially we it's going to be
something very very what's the word I'm
looking for
celebratory yeah it's going to be fun
we'll see what we're allowed to do
legally 200 episodes 200 hours of the
show 200 hours of content
it's a lot that's a lot all available on
the patreon it's a truly amazing time
we've watched the show gives birth to
the climate we're in now to a degree I
mean we've been a show that is focused
on the darker elements of human nature
that's where a lot of the comedy we do
comes from and now you know we focused
on the idea that we're going to live in
some [ __ ] dystopian nightmare reality
where Ellen DeGeneres would be
broadcasting from her room and then we'd
all be in Marshall on well here we are
here we go tell them what they've won
that's that's it's been amazing I mean
the way the world has changed in the
last few years I mean would you have
believed it no no everything's like
we're in physic we're on schedule yeah
that's what's really bad it actually
doesn't this is what's alarming to me
this is the craziest thing about this
whole period of time and maybe why I'm
less freaked out than everybody else it
feels exactly on schedule it feels like
exactly what was going to happen
happened and we're responding in the
ways that we are going to respond and
everything's moving along you know the
way that you would expect it to move
along incompetent gross
you know desperate yeah to free-for-all
people just trying to collect the last
bit of money yeah you know that they
tried to do with some sex
this Jacob wool you know that kid who's
always pulling those tricks he's always
trying to get people to accuse people of
sexual misconduct oh yeah yeah yeah him
and his in that guy Jack Burkman they're
like you know hucksters and wool and his
dad or like big Trump guys he was trying
to get somebody to
woman to claim that foul Chi like raped
her or something I mean every day it's
the same thing every year I mean every
week it's like the same it's the same
news cycle it's the same names it's the
same hucksters Candice Owens is in a
wall and I you know Whole Foods
somebody's bothering her you know the
same people same things on Twitter you
know the same people on Twitter
complaining about the real problems
right now or gender expression same
things the dells fad now she stand it's
the same it's boy it's boring life has
gotten deadly and boring the real the
real pandemic is boredom boredom with
the current climate of how we all relate
to each other and how we're all
manipulated all the [ __ ] time by the
same people at least give us new people
give us new leaders of the three-ring
circus we don't even have any of those
the same Trump and Pelosi and then AOC
you know it's the same characters I want
to change the channel I want to watch a
different show you know it's it's all
predictable you could lay it all you
could guess the news next week with some
regularity yeah and you'd be right
you know Trump will do this he's gonna
do that this person is gonna do that
these people are gonna get mad
celebrities gonna do something out of
touch they're gonna seem ridiculous
people are getting mad at them
somebody's gonna do that and then you
just end and round and round we go you
know but 200 episodes 200 episodes maybe
Johnny Gosch will come on the show how
great would that be
how great would be if Johnny Gosch came
on the show and he was like a
coronavirus truther will let Johnny tell
us the politicians who [ __ ] you and he
goes I want to talk about this fake
virus and we're like but Johnny you have
the chance to really really crack open
this case and talk about it
he goes the real concern I have is foul
Chi I'm like ouchy it's the little
Italian guy here's the thing with people
I love that like nobody knew who found
she was 3 months ago now he's the
Antichrist
it's amazing how quickly people become
the Antichrist God I think the devil is
kind of upset that like some [ __ ]
career career political hack in the
[ __ ] CDC's now the ante or whatever
the [ __ ] he does he's now the Antichrist
Satan's like get along I've been working
cultivating like this guy's a hack he's
an empty suit with a stethoscope and you
think he's the Antichrist you know and
I'm not defending I'm sure if out she's
dirty but like this whole idea that
everybody's a symbol of utter eaat most
evil there's no nobody's there's no
gradations there's no [ __ ] you know I
like this pillow by the way it's it's
it's shows you luxury burn the pillow so
what what what can we do for 200
episodes we're gonna try to get some
really cool guests a compilation of
people you know will probably be back in
the studio because we'll need that for
guests and we'll be out of this area
you know we thank you for listening if
you're a supporter of the show we
appreciate it we appreciate everybody on
patreon everybody who just listens to
the show if you can't afford patreon for
episodes a month we're always free you
know one Episode a week we appreciate
everybody that buys tickets to the live
stand-up shows that buys the merge which
is still available the link is on insta
we get it it's tough times right now if
you can't buy any of that don't worry
they'll still be a shitload of free
entertainment videos YouTube things like
that if you want to pay you'll get more
it's all about what you can do what you
can't do
it's a comedy show it should make you
laugh it should be funny it should
occasionally make you think you know you
know this is not medical advice show
should go without saying but it doesn't
now does it
you know people people message me there
why don't you go into the gene
sequencing what I mean you know this is
where comedy is it's happening right
here it'll eventually happen on a stage
again and then we'll do it there we'll
do it there cuz we're not gonna go legit
can't get real jobs you've gone too far
down the river gone too far down the
river 200 [ __ ] hours of talking that
is a lot of [ __ ] talking and then if
you got to add all the patreon episodes
- yeah a lot of talking man how many
episodes do you think we've done on
patreon would you guess around we've
done exactly 46 ok so it's like 246
hours of content yeah you know Wow
wild you know and are all of those
episodes available on patreon are now
246 yeah yeah well almost right it
should be like 170 because some are free
you know God the regular horse ride on
YouTube of course subscribe to the
YouTube channel if you are listening to
this Tim Dylan show on YouTube subscribe
you know some people enjoy watching the
show some people enjoy listening doesn't
matter it's the only thing that matters
is that you realize the strep throat
it's not real it's your kid trying to
get out of school conjunctivitis isn't
real smack them send them back out I
hope when we all go back out this would
be the greatest thing ever we all go
back out and we everybody goes back out
would you start doing the things we used
to do and then we look at everybody
we're like like literally in the middle
of like a dinner everyone's got drinks
and we're all eating or all happy to be
together and then like in the middle of
dinner we just say very casually like we
don't we're not even angry but would you
say very casually we kind of look at
each other we're like I hate you like
this is funny and we will start giggling
and we're like why are you laughing I
kind of hate you and you I also hate you
like I didn't miss you at all
this is horrible you know I think we
just keep chewing on chicken wings it
doesn't matter we just keep talking and
you know going on about our day but I
wish everybody here health I was your
happiness I wish you wealth I wish you a
stunning a steak I wish you all of the
tools you need I'd love to get that
woman Judy Miss commits whatever name is
from planned a makan oh I have her name
right here let's see yeah Judy Mick of
its McMicken it's dr. Judy mega Vince
dr. Mick Yvette's what a [ __ ] name
can't take somebody seriously Mick of
its and foul she sounds like a [ __ ]
vaudevillian comedy duo I'm going to see
mega vitsin foul Qi hilarious yeah
they're [ __ ] hilarious tease do you
know she went home she's all drunk she
look a kid she's like Anthony found she
is it tango [ __ ] [ __ ] and if he
opens his mouth and tries to talk over
me one more time I'm gonna [ __ ] cut
his little [ __ ] [ __ ]
like good night folks